our story begins like all great young
love stories she slayed him eidm he
liked about 50 of my photos back back in
the middle of the night way what I saw
was an artist committed to truth and
justice and she's beautiful but I
digress
our story actually begins across many
worlds over mokuba and Redwine in
Palestine but how did we get there well
I was born in Chicago the son of a
preacher and a teacher my ears first
rung with church song sung by my mother
on Saturday mornings
my father Southside sermons summoned me
my first words were more notes than
quotes it was music that molded me later
on it was Florida A&M University that
first introduced me to organizing in
2012 a young black male named Trayvon
Martin was murdered and it changed my
life and millions of others we were a
ragtag group of college kids and not
quite adults who had decided enough was
enough art and organizing became our
answer to anger and anxiety we built a
movement and traveled around the world
and to Palestine in 2015 I was born to a
single mother in the pink house projects
of Brooklyn New York madam by survival I
gravitated inward towards books poems
and my brothers hand-me-down Walkman I
sought train station theater sub wolfing
streets and hood murals in high school I
found a community of metaphor magicians
and truth-telling poets in an
organization called urban word NYC
adopted by the Black Arts Movement I won
the legendary New Year Rican poets cafe
Grand Slam title Sarah Lawrence College
I worked with artists to respond to
Hurricane Katrina and the earthquake I
discovered the impact of poetry in the
ability to not just articulate our
feelings but to get us to work towards
changing things and doing something
about it when a friend made the al-hasan
invited
me to Palestine we were a delegation of
artists and organizers and we immerse
ourselves in Palestinian culture music
the stories late into the night we would
have discussions about the role of art
in politics and the role of politics and
arts Audra and I disagree
oh we disagree but we quite quickly and
unsurprisingly fell in love exhibit a me
working my magic obvious isn't it
four months later this artist and this
organizer moved into a little home with
a big backyard in Miami
listen five months before this ever
happened I predicted it all I'm gonna
tell you my friend set me down and he
said you've done so much for organizing
when are you gonna settle down and I
looked him straight in the face and I
said the only way that it would ever
happen is if it is a collision this
woman would have to knock me completely
off course I didn't know how right I was
our first few months were like any
between young lovers filled with hot
passionate all night non-stop
discussions I challenged everything I
knew and understood about the world she
forced me to only to see our organizing
work with new eyes she helped me see the
unseen things and how artists illuminate
our interior worlds there were many days
I did not want to get up out of bed and
face the exterior world I was
discouraged there was so much loss and
death and artists were being used to
numb Lowell and exploit while winning
awards accolades and grants soothed so
many egos people were still dying and I
was seeking community meeting Phillip
brought so much joy love truths into my
life and it pulled me out of isolation
he showed me that community and
relationships wasn't just about building
great movements it was integral in
creating powerful meaningful art and
neither could be done in solitude yeah
we realize many of our artists and
organizer friends were also lost in
these cycles of sadness
and we were in movements that often
found themselves at funerals we asked
ourselves what becomes of a generation
all too familiar with the untimely ends
of lives stream daily on our timelines
it was during one of our late-night
discussions that we saw beyond art and
organizing and began to see that art was
organizing the idea was set art was an
anchor not an accessory to movement our
home was a home of radical imagination
and instrument of our nurturing hearts a
place of risk where we dare to laugh
love cry debate art books records and
all this stuff decorated our walls and
there was lizards walls of palm trees
that guided our guests into our back
yard where our neighbors would come and
feel right at home the wind the wind was
an affirmation for the people who walked
into the space and we learned that in a
world of the wildering world of so much
distraction we were able to cultivate a
space where people could come and be
present and artists and organizers could
find refuge this became smoke signal
studio as we struggle to clothes house
feed and educate our communities our
spirits hunger for connection joy and
purpose and as our bodies are out on the
front lines our souls still need to be
fed or else we succumb to despair and
depression our art possesses rhythmic
communication coated emotional cues
improvised feelings of critical thought
our social movements should be like jazz
encouraging active participation
listening spontaneity and freedom what
people see as a party is actually a
movement meeting see we aren't all
protest and pain here is a place to be
loved to be felt to be heard and when we
prepare for the most pressing political
issues in our neighborhoods see laws
never change culture but culture always
changes laws art art as organizing is
even changing and opening doors and
places seen as the opposite of freedom
our weekly poetry series is transforming
the lives of men incarcerated at a
correctional and we're so excited to
bring you all the published work of one
of those men Echo Martinez in the intro
he says poetry for the people is the
sick pens penicillin it's a cuff key to
a prisoner's dreams the Molotov and the
ink it is knowledge it is over standing
it is tasting the ingredients in
everything you've been force-fed but
most of all it's a reminder that we all
have voices we all can be heard even if
we have to scream in 2018 we created our
first annual maroon poetry festival at
the Takashi Center and Liberty City
they're the last poets Sonia Sanchez
Emory Douglas and the late great ntozake
Shange performed and met with local
artists and organizers we were able to
honor them for their commitment to
radical truth-telling
and in addition to that we transformed a
public park into the physical
manifestation of the world we are
organizing for everything that we put
into poetry we put into the art into the
creativity into the curated kids games
and into the stunning stage design our
work is in a long line of cultural
organizers they understood to use art to
animate a radical future artists like
June Jordan Emory Douglas and Nina
Simone they understood what many of us
are just now realizing that to get
people to build the ship you've got to
get them to long for the sea that data
really moves people but great art always
does this understanding this
understanding informed the thinking
behind the dream defenders freedom
papers a radical political vision for
the future of Florida that talked about
people over profits now we could have
done a policy paper instead artists and
organizers came together and their
poetry did it create incredible murals
and did
video that we see behind us we join the
political precision of the Black Panther
Party and the beautiful poetry of Puerto
Rican poet martín Espada to bring our
political vision to life now thousands
of Floridians across age race gender and
class see the freedom papers as a vision
for the future of their lives for
decades our our artists and our art has
been used to exploit lull numb sell
things to us and to displace our
communities but we believe that the
personal is political and the heart is
measured by what is done not what one
feels and so art as organizing is not
just concerned with artists intentions
but their actual impact great art is not
a monologue great art is a dialogue
between the artists and the people four
years ago this artist and this organizer
found that we were not just a match we
were a mirror our worlds truly did
collide and in many ways they combined
we learned so much about movement about
love and about art at its most impactful
when it articulates the impossible and
when it arose individualism when it
plays in the black and white in the
great places of our black and white
worlds when it does what our democracy
does not when it reminds us that we are
not Islands when it adorns every Street
but Wall Street and Madison Avenue when
it reminds us that we are not Islands
and refuses to succumb to the numbness
when it ignites Empire and inspires each
and every one of us to love tell the
truth and make revolution irresistible
for the Wizards
for the Wizards and ways of our defiance
love riot visions of our rising risen
race elves the overcoming grace fire
spitter tongues wise as rickety rocking
chairs suffering salt and sand skies
memories unshackled and shining stitches
on a stretch marked heart for the
flowers that bloom in midnight scars how
we suffered and sought a North Star when
there was no light we glowed we sparked
this rejoice this righteous the light we
have a cause to take joy in how we
weathered and persisted tenacious no
stone unturned how we witnessed the
horror of mankind and did not become
that which horrified us thank you thank
you
[Applause]